okay Omar yeah okay man it's soft it's
crumbling like mad what your foot man
just think about how great that foot is
gonna be surely it's an easier way down
just be careful over there because
there's a beehive right on your left
hand side oh
who stuck a beehive over the side of
this look at them don't bother them
please don't bother them
be careful no
[Music]
thank you
I'm in the state of Oaxaca southern
Mexico the spiritual home of that
delicious Molly
located nearly 300 miles Southeast of
Mexico City Oaxaca is a Bastion of
indigenous culture and incredible
produce it's a food destination that's
finally getting the tension it deserves
I'm on my way to meet the extraordinary
Gabriella camera one of Mexico's most
influential chefs now she's promised to
show me a side of oaxacan Cuisine that
very few people ever get to experience
foreign
wow this is beautiful welcome
Gabriella Camara is one of Mexico's most
respected chefs when she was 22 her
passion for Farm to Table Cuisine led
her to open Mexico City favorite Contra
ma two decades later she continues to
put her own twist to time honored
Traditions making her the star of modern
Mexican Cuisine good to see you my
darling my first time in Waka Oaxaca is
is a very complex part of Mexico in
Mexico everybody's very proud are you
from here I'm not from Oaxaca I grew up
closer to Mexico City right but Oaxaca
is the place for food everyone's talking
about the mole yes you know I've never
had a chance to master but are they that
good here I mean Oaxaca is
Molly is a rich multi-layered source
made from chili peppers fruits and
multiple nuts and spices it's very
complex it's very difficult to learn I
am very intrigued if you're gonna Master
Molly in a week we'll see
while mollies vary from Kitchen to
Kitchen many begin with chocolate so
Gabriella introduces me to Rayna Mendoza
the queen of cacao to teach me how to
make it from scratch
pleasure meeting you this is
and we in general
they use Comales to make everything to
make tortillas to roast different you
know the Chiles the cacao more here
this is a tradition yeah but it feels
like a ritual it's so much of a ritual
Cacao is really the beginning of the
festive mole preparation right it's very
important it smells delicious so good
one of the really wonderful things about
Molly is you use a lot of ingredients
there's corn you use Chile Chiles are
the other really fundamental thing for
foreign
with the skins of the cacao beans
removed it's time to grind them using a
50 year old tool that's being passed
down through Reyna's family
the cinnamon
there she starts
all the ingredients should be in the
center so they don't spread out right
just that's part of the technique
I want to see this I can't wait to see
this
is a nightmare it's hard to get a word
in edgeway so that's not normal for me
but I sit I listen I learn I'm get up to
speed
um so everyone thinks that's Mexican
Cuisine is
a simple sort of rustic Cuisine I mean
this is well this is this is why it's
important for you to be in Oaxaca
because Oaxaca is so complex culturally
yeah and then and the food is as complex
as the cultures
she says you need to relax because
because when we cook yes we are
transmitting our mood right into the
food so slow down slow down and enjoy it
she's saying that's the first time in my
career I've been told to slow down and
that's that's the opposite to how I work
so I think I'm in for a tough week
that
smells beautiful can we taste this now
please
so traditionally in Oaxaca chocolate is
no
man but chocolate is prepared with water
well that's just the start of the
process
I need to go through to get a mole
thank you
it smells festive
the cinnamon
it tastes so rich and it tastes like
there's milk or cream in there but it's
nice just water that's down to the
chocolate right
[Music]
chocolate is one of the very important
ingredients and now you're gonna go off
on adventures to learn about other
ingredients in a week you're gonna come
back and we're gonna cook and you're
gonna prove to me that you can cook
oaxacan meal so stop where are we going
into the hills into the hills it's going
to be an adventure maybe you'll suffer a
little bit
but you you seem to enjoy suffering a
little bit you ready I am
I've got only one week to learn about
one of the world's most complex Cuisines
before I go head to head with Gabriella
fortunately she's arranged for some of
her friends to help local guide Carlos
Guzman is taking me to meet them
now Carlos I'm heads and meet the man
called Omar to hopefully find some
delicious ingredients yeah just keep it
straight I can't go anywhere else can I
oh sorry
you are kidding me come on stop it
no be careful be careful you don't get
that close okay
what's up Gordon are you coming down
where's the buffet this way
come on down surely there's a road down
15 miles that way seriously yeah come on
come on
are you crazy no you have to repel down
mean
I came here determined to unlock the
secret of Molly
if I'd known the first step was to scale
a cliff I may have sent one of my Sous
chefs Garden is coming down watch out
Yo's like that man
want to step by one
man it's soft
it's crumbling like mad what's your foot
man you think about how great that food
is gonna be it's hard to get your feet
in because it just
it Slips Away
surely it's an easy way down just be
careful over there because there's a
beehive right on your left hand side
you stuck a big high on the side of this
look at them
don't bother them please don't bother
them
there you go
good job bloody hell some call Omar
Alonso The Unofficial mayor of Oaxaca
good to see you guys his friend Pepe
carazoza grew up on this land and has
foraged it since he was a child so these
ingredients are somewhat unique right
this is the only place where you can
find them right and it's very unique how
you find them and where you find them
because it's not like they're laying
around somewhere you know gotcha so are
these mainstream ingredients or is this
a wild ingredient this is a wild
ingredient and we are right here what's
the ax for chopping down the cactus no
what about right there
what the hell what the tree trunk do you
see that
oh are you serious yeah
inside here is like breaking a pinata
you know you break it and you you see
what's in it there's ingredients in here
there's food in there yeah no we just
need to get it out
one
[Laughter]
what the hell can we decide this log
you're praying when you're cooking
against Gabriela
Pepe said this was like breaking a
pinata there you go
uh no but I've never been to a birthday
party and seen a blindfolded kid
swinging an ax
oh you just killed our food I think
well look at the bright side we're gonna
have plenty of firewood
ah what is that
what a grub that's a gusano yeah
a bloody word see if this is what's
inside of a oaxacan pinata whoa it's
biting me
please don't invite me to your kids next
birthday party
I listen I have a bad bad history of
worms we're not eating these things raw
are we no we're not we've got to cook
them now you see how delicious they're
gonna turn
honestly I don't think I've ever been so
happy to eat cooked worms this is it
this is it no salt no pepper no nothing
okay pick your warm and then cook it the
way you want pick my word over easy so
I'll go for this one here okay Peppa
that's yours
so when would you eat this in the winter
when it gets cold
this this will be the protein people
survive on these things in the winter
yeah can you see that laid on top of a
delicious Molly negro oh yes definitely
I'm not too sure well this is what we
want the color that texture yeah and the
color oh they smell good already all
right go for it go first because you're
our guest I'm hoping they taste better
than they look come on because they
don't look very advertising any last
words you would like to see so you just
take a bite crunch it chew on it yeah
okay
[Music]
I mean the hills outside Oaxaca and my
guides Omar and pepe are introducing me
to one of their favorite snacks okay
I can't say I share their enthusiasm
[Music]
it's very pasty it's very mealy it's did
it taste I bought it to you butter no it
tasted like sawdust gone warm creamed up
and pepper salad
[Music]
we're good
um not for me I feel kind of bad you
didn't like them and I'm gonna give it a
second try if you're up for it something
also very very unique and interesting
let's go
can't be difficult on the back of that
liquid worm
if I'm gonna compete on Gabriella's
Manor even though they're not my cup of
tea I've got to think of a way of using
those worms for sure it's going to be
sweeter sweeter unique also right what
we're looking for we're looking for a
honey ants honey ants yes here yeah Omar
tells me that these ants come out at
night and collect nectar from the plants
and trees around them to produce their
own kind of honey that's the food for
the rest of the colony well how did you
get the honey from
oh you just put it in your mouth and I
just put in your mouth they're gonna pop
the cool thing is that the ant doesn't
die so you just like pop it drink the
honey and then you just put the Ant back
into the hole ready yeah oh there's some
ants okay so that's a good sign okay go
for it just lay down a little okay
Gordon
oh my god look how many we found
that's all honey yeah but it looks like
a ball yeah it's their belly really yes
there's a hole full of sacks
how beautiful are they wow wow that's
plenty three four five they're all
different sizes two they're beautiful
and why aren't they biting because
they're what happens they're friendly
the actual sack is connected to the body
and they're like little balloons
aren't they Absolutely Amber you know
so just bite the belly you just
literally suck on its sack yeah
delicious yes it tastes like sort of
sweet honey stroked cider vinegar but my
main course this one's my appetizer
oh I did just go for it
[Laughter]
pretty unique isn't it yes
and he's still alive no it's sweet so
how come it's so sweet because of what
they collect a night all of the flowers
and the nectar from the different plants
around them and would you cook with them
or just I think it'll be really hard for
you to collect a lot of them yeah
the ants were delicious but I can't
transport them because you suck that
belly off the ant that's a little
treasure a little nugget of magic that
Oaxaca has as a secret ingredient that I
can't take that was delicious I'm glad
that you like it but we're not quite
done yet we have another surprise for
you one more one more as tasty as that
yes yes that was way better than the
worms by the way yeah
that right there there's a tree
look deeper
what is that it's a waste pipe
why why are we collecting wasps there's
larvae but also honey in it what's dough
produce honey they do they'll be
surprised Pepe is he serious see
you ready but
stop it
you gotta put that on first will they
get angry let's say they wouldn't enjoy
our company putting on a protective suit
is never a good sign apparently
Gathering the larvae requires a lot of
courage and a touch of crazy
yeah all right the plan is to tie a rope
to the tree and shake it into all the
wasps have left the nest
how many wasps are in there roughly
five thousand five thousand Watts yes so
right now they're all sleeping yes
they're called because of the weather
changed
wait wait wait wait wait perfect
dozens of wasps inside that little nests
um you don't want to piss off a hive
anytime yeah
this is his back Garden so you know he
was right up there tying the sort of
lasso and then we were tugging and
pulling all of a sudden they started
coming out I think this is a bit crazy
for ingredients
okay stop stop
this is crazy
what's he doing she's shaking it
do you see me what's leaving CCI yeah
there's a lot of them
he's gonna he's getting them a machete
he's gonna fight them
[Music]
I'm in the hills of Oaxaca attempting to
harvest was larvae for my final cook
he's gonna he's getting the machete
machete he's gonna fight them
[Applause]
but the two guys I'm with seem hell-bent
on making sure I don't get there
5000 wasps it's not a dangerous thing to
do down there
yeah oh he got it are they all gone
they're all gone it looks like it this
is as soft as papers layer by layer you
have to break it up
oh that honey this look you see it this
bit here's a honeycomb yes you want to
get it off the branch
okay
this is going to be your second weapon
in the cookout at the end
oh that looks good shall we shall we try
it so I had no idea that wasps produce
honey
you have to eat the whole thing cheers
guys
no it's so delicious
that is so sweet cracking this like
paper mache skull open and you've got
these incredible little compartments
that are laced with the most amazing
honey not as sweet as B honey but so
delicious oh my God the honey is great
but the main ingredient is the larvae
that you're gonna find in there oh my
God look at that
yeah that's the lava there okay
so that's the so they're wasp eggs and
so what would you do with the lava so
you cook them and then you make sauce
with it
wow there you go and so what what's in
here you've got lava what else is in
there garlic onion Chile water salt
hmm
wow that is beautiful it's definitely
given me some great ideas ahead of the
final cook
for me it's interesting to see what
Oaxaca has to offer and these
ingredients are seconds are done yeah we
have it all delicious good job seriously
I'm starting to get up to speed with the
oaxacan DNA now it's more than just
chocolate this has got incredible layers
that are in abundance
[Music]
with only a few days left until the
final cook I need to go big or go home
if I'm gonna have any chance of beating
Gabriella
and that means I need to get my hands on
a world-class Molly so I've asked foodie
Nikki to introduce me to a local Legend
now Nikki you said you're gonna take me
to a guy that produces the best Molly in
Oaxaca yes so he is right over here
Jorge they call him because his Molly is
that good seriously yeah what in here
yeah it's right here you see the design
I'll Fontina I can't wait alfonsina
this place looks beautiful there's Jorge
ah ho hey hey good morning good morning
you good
nice to meet you nice to meet you
absolute pleasure yeah so this is
this is a family restaurant a family
recipe all upstairs right big secret
I'll keep it a secret I promise okay for
the first step Jorge has me blister
tomatoes and tomatillos
see
next while I clean and remove the seeds
from the chilies
different nuts and spices on the Kamal I
got up to speed with making chocolate
and what else
is going into this thyme oregano sesame
seeds raisins garlic almonds and
cinnamon and then the onions are going
to roast onto the coals exactly there's
nothing measured out Hawaii's just he's
just cooking with the eyes is that
disconfidence I think it's just practice
a lot of practice cooking with your
heart is going to give a lot of flavor
essentially so that's the chili that you
just cleaned so now you can mix
everything together yep
one of the best patches I've ever had in
my life
clearly one of the cheapest
with the almost dizzying variety of
spices and nuts we add of all things oh
it's hot
roasted plantains
I mean I just love the smell of this it
smells incredible all in with a plantain
right exactly tell you what I'm gonna
look at cardboard in a completely
different way now
honestly once the tomatoes have cooked
they're added to the toasted and roasted
ingredients
so beautiful it smells Smoky
the seats on the beginning yeah taking
the seeds from the clean chili pods
Jorge has me light them on fire
for
flavor
perhaps the first time I've ever
intentionally burned my food so that
smells good it smells really good so
this is where the hard work really
begins hold on a minute see Hawaii's
been cooking Molly every day since she
was 14. not a day in a culinary school
and just that that level of knowledge he
has is extraordinary
it smells delicious but it does look
like something inside of a diaper
doesn't it
now that you've learned how to make a
proper mole you have to learn how to
make proper tortillas man
[Music]
while hohai finishes the grinding and
cooking of the mole he sends me off to
meet his mother Elvia hola hola
Gordon she'll be showing me how she
makes her soft tortillas
so now look right
just a gentle press there yeah
yeah
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
what happened that's not right
just with one hand you can't use both of
your hands down yeah okay apparently two
hands aren't always better than one
leave it to the wackens and they're
complicated Cuisine to make a Michelin
star Chef feel like a total donkey okay
I've got it I got it okay okay
slowly we're getting there it takes a
few tortillas but I finally start to get
the hang of it
okay
it's your last test
[Music]
she's saying Get out no
she says you know you're learning it's
going okay okay
I finally got elvia's stamp of approval
but something tells me she's not
offering me a job you are an amazing
artist I mean pretty people clearly it
runs in the family right absolutely is
the Molly ready no I will know
apparently there's one other thing that
she wants to show us after you please
man making Molly can be an all-day
process and instead of me hovering
around waiting for a taste Elvia has
found a way to keep me busy
[Music]
pleasure meeting you
this is a traditional healing practice
oh you want to heal my body yeah that's
right
this is stop you're going to get into
this little oven right here this is a
what's like a steam room yes on the
floor
Elia will be show me a Temescal so
you're gonna have to take your clothes
off it's the first step mama I love you
dearly
yeah start naked in the neighborhood
come on all of your clothes I wouldn't
do that to the ladies she has a blanket
and a blanket you can cover yourself
with a blanket thank you okay close your
eyes
[Laughter]
okay get the blanket on girl please just
in case the neighbors are peeping
Elia begins rubbing me with a herb mix
to open my paws
or maybe she's seizing me at this point
it's too early to tell oh not too far
down there not too far down there is it
burning a bit it is in my crack yes
so she's going to go in first okay
coming again
the things I do for food
I'm in Oaxaca and my journey to tasting
a delicious molly I got this have taken
a detour to a full body cleanse in a
tiny sweat lodge
now it's very steamy in here she's laid
down next to me now okay oh okay so you
should hold my hand in the air where the
hot steam is oh
okay Gordon you're ready
[Laughter]
I came for an amazing understanding how
to make a mole I had no idea I'd be
getting naked
in somebody's garden please may I have
some Wally now of course
but I do have the magic and I feel
cleansed
oh my God thank you that looks beautiful
that's delicious see very delicious it's
rich
charcoal spicy
so what you're trying here is Oaxaca wow
so rich
indeed no take a jar for the final cook
because there's no way I can make that
in one day
that is Magic in a jar mole is the the
essence of oaxacan Cuisine but that
stuff doesn't take two three hours to
make that takes sometimes days so
caption that magic in that jar I feel
like I've got a bit of a head start
um where's my clothes
oh yeah they're right over here I think
they're baking on top yes thank you
day before the final cook and if there's
one true oaxacan ingredient other than
Wally that I need to compete against
Gabriella it's Mezcal make no mistake
Mezcal it's not the same as tequila both
come from the agave plant but Mezcal is
produced in small batches and considered
more artisanal than tequila
now I know it's still early but Gary
said there's a local man called Armando
who produces one of the best mascals
anywhere in Mexico
hello my friend hey how are you what a
beautiful place welcome good to see you
good to see you now this is incredible a
guy before Mr Agave from Moscow yes now
Gabby said that you're producing some of
the best Mezcal anywhere in Mexico what
makes it so special here uh it's not
machines it's all it's all by hand your
flavor profile is somewhat unique it's
smoky smoky look at this
inside with Harbors wow the government
Savages by hand so they look like giant
pineapples yes it is it's about 100 100
kilos each each one because
uh tell her to take a break tea time
it's your turn
please gotcha
uh right so you're gonna make this easy
are you
to get to the Pina of the Agave Armando
first has me remove the spiny leaves oh
my gosh I'm getting there
let's say I will never hire you again
give me time okay okay this is slightly
different to the kind of knives I use
come on Gordon this is your first one
you have 40 more garbage 40 more yes so
literally you go through 40 of these a
day it's around four times a day for
each guy
uh
do you have any blisters
I've got blisters but come on how do we
get this into Moscow next up is uh grind
the garbage and ferment it gotcha so
it's it's a long process it's not
Tequila No so you think it's the hard
part it's not
once we cut this you have to lift it we
have to watch they have to pull it out
from there with the hands from the
ground hold on man yes how the hell do
you pull that out of the ground
to remove the Agave Armando uses aikoa a
long handle blade that cuts the bulb
from The Roots left in the ground
yes okay
just go ahead and
[Music]
what do you think what do I think
come on surely I've heard a drink now
this
man you'll want tough cookie now
for the Majestic bit
the exciting part yes
I said thank you
it smells slightly smoky it's working
sweet
here's to the blisters
foreign
wow it's very smoky now I understand
that process that's a process and it's
sweet as well what's the difference
between Mezcal tequila it's giving me
some ideas for the cook maybe marinade
maybe finish yeah definitely but uh it's
pure class that's a labor of love right
there
it's a powerful liquor without doubt and
it's Unique again just another layer of
what Oaxaca has to offer I just got to
put into practice now and hopefully
do it justice
the day of the final cook has finally
arrived and I'm meeting Gabby at a local
mezgel Distillery
it's time to put all that I've learned
to the test in a true oaxacan Showdown
Gabby what happened to you I'll be busy
here so good to see you
my God how have you been of course I
started what do you mean I'm gonna let
you win no way extraordinary Weak by the
way oh good seriously you said get out
there and find something off the beacon
track and did you
[Music]
it's the day of the final cook and Chef
Gabriella Camaro and I will be duking it
out using some of oaxaca's most local
ingredients you said get out there and
find something off the Beaten Track and
did you
e please tell me we haven't got these
incredible worms I don't I'm hoping I
have got up to speed with the the DNA of
oaxacan Cuisine than Wally magical right
I had no idea how long a sophisticated
Molly takes to cook and we were there
all day yes you didn't tell me how to
get naked for a steam room after it come
on you get naked in front of the ladies
I had a towel but I was like I bet you
they were more mortified than you were
what happens in the steam room stays in
the steam room right now there's Molly
to be made
so I'm gonna do Molly three ways okay
you spoke about the Molly negro with the
the chocolate right yes so I'm going to
start off with uh braising my chicken
okay so you chose the chicken for the
morning okay and then I've got some pork
and loin shoulder and what's that gonna
be for I'm gonna shred that and put that
inside the Chile reyno okay
look at you you said get up to speed yes
I did tell me what we do I am making
hold on
you're using this well who sent you
there what do you think I'm not going to
use it of course I'm going to use it
hold on a minute girl yes we're using
the same base
this is mole negro but you know what it
never is the same only because you
always add things onto it that's a big
kick in The Goonies for me no and you
know what I'm doing go on I'm using
turkey instead of chicken I'm not a big
fan of turkey turkey was the bird that
people had here before the Europeans got
here ready I'm gonna use the brown meat
of the turkey shred it right whenever
you let me use the grill because you're
very
I was giving it a bit of space sorry
please I get excited with these kind of
stoves good everything's Smoky here yes
everything's Smoky why is that is that
because of the style of the cooking or
we cook with fire here well I've got
some space here for you now okay I'm
coming
Gabby definitely needs room on the grill
because in addition to her black molly
she's making a green Molly this is
that spicy no it's lovely parsley garlic
also dried shrimp right and a yellow
molly as well
that's three mollies if you're keeping
score at home is that too much color on
the pumpkin you're happy with that I'm
happy you sure yeah I know the mascara
needs to be Smoky but do you want to
smoke your pumpkins that much yes I'm
loving them just asking that's all
if it was to deglaze the worms with a
touch of Mezcal it's very Frenchy of you
but go ahead I'm just hoping they're
going to be a bit of a delicacy mascal
on tap come on girl that is beautiful
Frenchy Frenchy oh there you go
I really want to see what the Mexicans
think of these just a little flambe come
on
oh my God
smell in there
thank goodness regarding I tell you I
never thought I'd say that but those
worms look delicious if I'm gonna go
down today I'm gonna go down in flames
seriously
how are you doing with your dishes yeah
I'm a little bit behind I need to fry my
chili oregano yeah
that takes a long time you're late you
are on it aren't you I am I hope so
okay can we go back on the stove now
please oh you're hugging the stove well
that's no I'm not
um I only have this little tiny pot come
on
due to arrive any minute and three more
days in the works we're both feeding the
Heat
come on
okay give me more than okay please
made it come on yes
El Molly started it I'm finishing it so
yours is darker than mine because I
didn't add tomato did you want tomato I
did yes I didn't Tomatoes Tomatoes The
Wasp larvae sauce
huh come on
you like that there's no okays there you
know that's good it's really good then a
little nuttiness like exactly the little
bit at the end
right oh his I guess hola
my new oaxacan friends from the past
week have arrived
why they almost killed me the hard work
was necessary and I hope they can taste
it in my dishes
no no no no you're starting to feel the
pressure I am I'm nervous about this
meal
queso fresco just to finish those chili
touch more chocolate on the chicken
you're fancying it up I'm using every
trick in the book just to stay in the
same Lane those are your tricks
Madame Madame are you done I didn't
think I was going to say this but I'm
nearly done
so am I my dear
okay
done
amazing that looks beautiful you know
what we didn't make the tortillas oh
really
oh my God
we didn't make the tortillas oh really
oh bollocks our oaxacan experts are
seated and waiting but we're missing a
fundamental element of any Mexican meal
freshly made Tortillas not too hard
you're already squishing it okay now the
difficult part that's too thin
I don't know what good of a teacher
Elvia was
shall we yes oh my God yes the moles are
hot and ready so I guess we'll have to
live without tortillas it's time to find
out if I've been able to scratch the
surface of what I now know is one of the
world's most complicated Cuisines so
nice to see you all
okay first of all I would like to
apologize for the tortilla
yeah my fault my three dishes the first
one is a chicken done with that Molly
negro I put a little bit more extra
chocolate in there enriching it the
second dish is the beautiful chili arena
with some braised pork and that's with a
almost like a tomato base mole a bit
sweeter and the third dish is the
tostada with the special worms the
protein caramelized glaze Mezcal Madam I
made with your black mole I put turkey
in it and I made it into tostadas
with plantains and then
with shrimp a little bit of nopales the
paddles and then the molia with the
grilled squash and the shoots and the
blossoms of the squash so it's a squashy
dish
es
enjoy please gracias
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
yeah so they dig it in I mean I'm
nervous just because these are the
experts you know sure look at the Talon
on that table
which one was your favorite Nikki chile
rellenos are usually really like juicy
and this was a bit dry but you know we
were really missing the tortillas I'm
more nervous about Mr mole in terms of
what he thinks of my Malay no no I I
agree I hope we didn't mess it up
because I'm on the same boat as you say
is
okay we have a winner then
it's judgment time you ready to go let's
go good luck
good luck huh
okay
yeah
this week's been all about the mole
right so uh whatever the result is trust
me I have an extraordinary week let me
tell you but should we start off with
the the green Molly well green Molly was
amazing it was definitely very original
the way we ate it in a tostada we all
felt like the worm was kind of lost in
it because we didn't even feel it it got
lost with all the textures and uh the
one with the shrimp got a little bit
extra salt that we all liked however we
decided that the winner for the green
mole had to be the tostada
wow good for you that's a strong start
I'm impressed well that repel was worth
it after all told you okay and then what
did we think of the Colorado and
amarillito
a few of us said that the amarillito was
very original and we had never had it
like that with squash and for the chile
relleno we thought that the feeling was
a bit boring and that made the Chile a
little bit dry
so for the second uh course we decided
that the winner
uh is the amarillito with the squash
beautiful dish thank you thank you so
what comes down to the poly negro
Gabby and I have each scored with one
dish the tiebreaker will be our versions
of that complex black molly based on El
moles mole which can only mean one thing
I think that whoever is going to decide
who takes the win for the black model
has to be Jorge
ous
oh my goodness is it the turkey or is it
the chicken
chicken
Gordon
the foundation was set from you let me
tell you for both these dishes so you've
been an amazing teacher and and you guys
have just helped me understand what
Oaxaca has to offer on the heart so um
I've had an amazing week I'm so happy
that you came
thank you thank you so much for coming
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you
I've learned so much this week and now I
truly understand why Oaxaca is the
Connery capital of Mexico
I've scanned the countryside for
delicious insects
prepared a complicated world-class Molly
with a certified master
and harvested spiny Agave for that Smoky
mezcal
the complex flavors the rich history is
why this has to be one of my favorite
destinations yet and now on to our next
adventure
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you